[Music]
thank you
this is the legend of a soldier and his
girl
of his family of the town he was born in
and of the death that flies by Night the
small singing death the Annapolis
mosquito bearer of the plague of malaria
it's a true legend it has happened it
will happen again over and over in a
hundred American sounds unless we stop
it from happening
the soldier is home on lead from the
traffic
he's never had an attack of malaria but
he has been sickly too weak to do his
job
the drugs he has taken have kept down
the symptoms
he does not know that he bears in his
bloodstream the deadly plasmodium
sarsaparum organism of the virulent
tropical malaria he feels better he's
glad to be home
he walked with his girl after supper
full in reunion peaceful in the Lost
the Catalpa the last Light over the lake
he brushes his cheeks but the mosquito
has taken her blood meal and drifted out
from under his hands now the cycle
Begins the young Soldier becomes the
innocent bringer of Misfortune and death
to his people
the soldier was the first to fall sick
not because the mosquito bit him but
because he felt better at home neglected
the drugs he needed
they taken to the new military Hospital
the commandant an old Panama hand
recognizes the disease he warns the
county health officer
this is the Soldier's town a clean
modern Town busy with the business of
War
the town is in a malarial district a few
dozen cases each year the milder endemic
frame
a long drag on the health of the people
a little bitching a little draining of
fun but no long-term control no planned
cooperation between Town and County and
state no settled program
now out beyond the limits of the Town a
new danger way
a wet spring and a rainy summer
the epidemic seventh year of the
malarial cycle
in the borough pits and lime sinks in
the ponds and swamps and impounded
Waters
along the stagnant Creeks bordered with
the growth of parrot feathers and
lizard's tail and wolf yellow
the Annapolis mosquitoes and the
infected blood of the soldier breed
together
the nearby army training field is a
protected area but a flying Cadet is
bitten or closed in the hotel port in
town
two or three weeks later The
bone-shaking Kills of falca Parham catch
him in the air
[Music]
the trash truck can be ambulance
he wavers in like a storm where he goes
bright thoughts
fight the flame down
rolls Down The Long runway in the Sun
too weak to climb out
the ambulance men get him down
transferring to the military Hospital
a truck driver yours off the road
malaria is a favorite disease of poverty
in the bottom
but it strikes high and lower light
the manufacturer's wife
the small boy calling for his mother
an old friend consult dust a hill
and Dr Hill's 20-year demand for
adequate malaria control reaches a
boiling point
foreign well we'll find out
the microscope won't ride
even wet and naughty
tell her I'll be around this afternoon
parasite
so
[Music]
I'll tell you you go along and go to bed
I'll send you out from quinine and I'll
see you later
sit down here Fred
I'm going to take you home myself
Brazilian get me the county health
office right away please
the county health officer calls a
meeting at the courthouse
[Music]
such as men trucks or others that we
have our children schools
epidemic before
without half of our people
the mayor goes to work on the newspaper
editor with an educational campaign in
mind
the State Board of Health Branch reports
on a series of New Blood specimens
the only mosquito control agency in the
district the university Field Station
the director explains the water table
lays out a campaign to establish the
main centers of anopheles breeding
the catalpas at the lake where the
soldier Was Bitten
[Music]
a good Hall of adult monopolies from the
wedi island offshore
thick blood smear and Azure strain
positive but the patient is already dead
the inspector sucks up a sleeping quad
the mosquitoes seem to prefer the
company of Sig
another inspector picks them off the hay
the state malaria control engineer takes
the hand in the hunt the squirming lavae
thick at mossipon
the epidemic moves up to a Peak at the
end of summer
there are many deaths
the total Magnolia has a free hole near
its base crowded with sleeping adults
the dead anopheles lie like fluffed in
the chlorophon tube
the story of malaria moves into the
stool
the control measures begin
in the soldiers room the inspector finds
a warped screen a good screen might have
helped to save the town from an epidemic
he opens the jet of the aerosol bomb
Freon perathrum and oil of Sesame are
powerful safe insecticide
Paris Greene blows out over the swamp
water in a shining cloud
[Music]
free-flowing water tends to prevent the
growth of eggs and love eyes
even a fish pool needs to be dusted
the cadet is back in harness
all over the country fuel Crews put in
the foundations of a long-range control
program and praying in dragline dishing
line conduits and a spray gun used at
home
the big truck blower that Roars out over
the lime sinks
but the dead have died the lesson is
learned the anopheles will vanish the
epidemic will fade out in the cooler
weather of autumn
the town will flourish again and the
soldier will come home to his family and
his girl
[Music]